chris evans recently made a comment that
he was considering quitting acting in
favour of directing that's cool man
direct a movie I'll watch it but don't
stop acting man cuz you're doing a good
job
[Music]
snowpiercer is a film starring Chris
Evans Jamie Bell John Hurt Tilda Swinton
and quite a bit of other people and a
few people that are pretty awesome that
I don't want to spoil for you because
it's just best they did not know that
they're in the movie this is a movie
that has been surrounded by a lot of
controversy largely because it was
directed by a Korean filmmaker who's
very talented he made the film the host
and when this film premiered at various
festivals critics loved the movie but
the production company was fearful that
mainstream audiences weren't gonna get
into this movie and they were
considering editing a large portion of
it just to make it more mainstream I
guess after a lot of outrage from not
just fans but critics who loved the film
as well they decided to show the film
and it's uncut glory thank goodness so
in this film mankind is largely extinct
the entire world is frozen and the
majority of mankind now resides on a
constantly moving train the people who
are more towards the front of the train
are living in luxury the people who are
more towards the back are the exact
opposite eventually a revolt is planned
and led by Chris Evans who wants to take
everyone in the back all the way to the
front where they will meet Wilfred who's
basically God now because the world is
not viewed as a planet anymore it's just
this train I'm very disappointed in the
way that snowpiercer is being released
it's a very strange release it's
basically wide except you kind of have
to go out of your way to find a theatre
that's showing it the closest theatre in
my house has like 30 40 minutes away
which is kind of stupid because this
movie is one of the best films I've seen
all year this is a incredibly original
and unique film that looks beautiful
that has very very good action sequences
but aren't filmed in your stereotypical
Hollywood fashion there is a little
shaky cam but it's the best shaky cam
I've seen all year in regards to the way
they use it it's a stunningly
photographed movie with excellent
performances the best I have ever seen
from Chris Evans he has a full wide
range of emotions on display in this
movie there's a lot of really great
character development in this film as
well it's not just a post-apocalyptic
action film this movie is at its core a
drama with some really great sequences
involving awesome stunt work but for the
most part this is a very dark film with
a lot of really hidden themes and when
you really start to think about what
this movie's actually about it becomes
kind of profound this movie has a lot to
say about the way mankind views their
society about the way from youth up you
are taught in a certain way to think of
the world in a certain way the way
religion can encroach upon society the
way politics can encroach upon society
the way the media controls things all of
this is explored throughout this film
that at its core is about a revolt to
take the head of a train but if you
really look under the surface there's a
lot going on in snowpiercer it had me
enthralled from start to finish but it's
also technically and aesthetically a
fantastic film to watch and listen to
Marco Beltrami score is riveting the
performances in the movie as I said are
all excellent you really feel this
bleakness to all the people who reside
in the back car who are constantly
beaten their children are taken away
from them they're forced to eat these
little grimy protein bars all day
Octavia Spencer has a role in this film
not just her normal kind of silly I'm
gonna tell a joke every once in a while
role that I actually won her an Oscar
she got a really physical role in this
movie and she kicked butt I mean she was
really good in this film but I got to
give serious props to Chris Evans cuz he
was so good with the stunt work in this
movie but his performance was
heartbreaking
he was truly excellent in this movie the
best I've ever seen him snowpiercer is a
film that is so blazingly original that
is so against the mainstream
entertainment that we are so used to
seeing nowadays that this film should
not be missed if you have a theater near
you or even semi near you that is
showing snowpiercer I implore you to go
and buy a ticket because I'm going to
buy this film on blu-ray the day it is
released I think snowpiercer
is an excellent film the action
sequences in the film are absolutely
thrilling
the dramatic aspect of the film works
very well the performances are excellent
and there's a lot of disturbing
metaphors to this movie about humanity
society religion politics and how all of
that can blend together and sometimes be
really disgusting I'm gonna give
snowpiercer an a definitely check this
film out it is worth your time avoid the
Hollywood stuff coming out this weekend
just go see
snowpiercer it is a different movie I
really hope more people see it if you've
seen the film I'm interested in knowing
what you thought of it and what is your
favorite Korean film think about that
for a while that might take you some
time
as always guys thank you so much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck by next
[Music]